hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
early on in book one of his treaties on
anger Seneca is going to provide us with
and then consider several different
definitions of anger so we have a clear
idea what we're actually thinking about
and and reading about and considering as
we go through the work and the first one
that he provides is probably the not
only the briefest but the most popular
but it's not a very good definition
actually because it doesn't tell us that
much you've probably run across it if
you have looked anywhere about Seneca on
anger and he says some wise people have
said that anger is a brief Madness
brevium insomnium right so a Insanity
that has a short duration while you're
actually angry and he does follow it up
saying it's no less lacking in
self-control forgetful of decency
unmindful of personal ties unrelentingly
intent on its goals shut off from
rational deliberation stirred for no
substantial reason unsuited to
Discerning what's fair and true just
like a collapsing building that's
reduced to Rubble even as it crushes
what it falls upon now that's a very
interesting metaphor but you know other
than saying yeah anger does these things
and it's like a kind of craziness or
Insanity that doesn't tell us how anger
really functions and so what we want to
look at instead are the three
definitions that he's going to provide
one right after another one of which is
being attributed to poseidonius who is
in fact a stoic no longer just a wise
man the first one is probably a stoic
definition question Scholars think that
the third one may in fact be coming from
epicureans and Seneca is willing to draw
upon epicureans when he finds it useful
and then he looks at one of Aristotle's
definitions as well so these are a
little bit more
extensive you could say or focusing in
on the actual topic so let's look at
these three definitions first he begins
by saying anger is the desire kapitas
right a word that he's going to use at
several different points a a lust you
could translate it as a strong desire as
it gets translated in the Aristotle's
definition a desire for what
taking Vengeance now we're actually
getting to what anger is about it's not
just being insane it's not just
derailing reason it is about taking
Vengeance uh Okie steady eye right for a
wrong in urea somebody has to do
something that either is an actual wrong
or is just perceived as a wrong
otherwise you don't really have anger
and then the next two definitions are
going to bring in some some new aspects
right so the one that's attributed to
post Adonis a desire to punish the
person now it's no longer just Vengeance
but punishment
and there's an additional aspect by whom
you reckon puto right so you think you
deem that you were unjustly
harmed iniqui license and so there's a
sense no longer of just in uh in injury
but also harm in some respect and that
it was done wrongly it was done wickedly
right so it was done without Justice or
contrary to Justice and then the third
he says is anger is the arousal of the
mind so now we've got this in kittium a
you know being
stirred up and that's also part of the
you know way anger manifests itself an
arousal of the mind and here he uses
to harm in three different places to
harm adnoken so that's what you're
intending to do you want to harm the
other person but why do you want to harm
the other person to harm the person who
has either harmed one right no career
right the person who has actually done
the harm to you or
wished to do so intended to do so you
think that they want to harm you right
so with each of these we're sort of
adding components to the understanding
of what it is that this passion of anger
actually consists in and he actually
considers some counter arguments against
this the first is a little bit
fragmentary and he says you know why
does the crowd become angry with
Gladiators so unfairly that it thinks it
is an offense they're not glad to Die
the crowd judges it's being treated with
contempt and it changes from spectator
to opponent whatever that sort of thing
is it's not really anger but just
something that looks like anger and he
brings up children who want to Pummel
the ground if they've Fallen who don't
even know that they're angry they are
without a reason and without being wrong
yet not without a certain impression of
being wronged and not without some
desire for payback and so their their
payback is imaginary as he says it's
against inanimate objects whereas real
anger is against things that we think
are animate things that we think do have
intentions to harm us did so wrongly and
all of that and we can put that aside a
more interesting objection is this we
become angry often not with people who
have harmed us but with those who intend
to harm us from this it's clear that
anger is not the product of a wrong and
Seneca says no no that's not a good
counter argument that actually
reinforces what I'm saying he says we do
become angry with those who intend to
harm us but they harm us by that very
intention one who intends to commit a
wrong is already committing it so in a
way anger grasp the motive of the other
person they could be threatening they
could just be intending they could be
planning and we get angry at them as a
way of retaliating for something they
have haven't yet done but have in mind
that they want to do for our conveying
to us that they want to do
he says another objection it's clear
anger is not a desire for payback why
because the very weakest people are
often angry at the most powerful they
don't desire a payback they have no hope
of achieving now this actually is an
objection
that uh is similar to points made by
Aristotle saying we don't get angry at
those who we can't actually get any
retribution against and Seneca says I
think he's quite right about this it's
the desire for exacting a payback not
the capacity to do so and people do
desire things they cannot achieve and
then he says in the second place no one
is so lowly he cannot conceive a hope of
making even the loftiest pay we are all
quite capable when it comes to doing
harm even if it's just in our
imagination even if it's just posting
impotently on social media and saying so
and so is a bad person oh you know
something like that Seneca thinks that
that's that's anger right so so these
definitions do in fact work and then
here he turns to look at Aristotle's
definition now we should be very clear
that this is only one of several
definitions that Aristotle does provide
of anger he discusses anger in such a
way as to give a definition in the
rhetoric book two which Seneca is not
referencing here in the topics and in on
the soul and so
in on the soul he says that we could
look at anger in several different ways
we could look at it in a physical ways a
boiling of blood around the heart notice
that Seneca is not worried about that
here but we could also look at it as a
strong desire to return pain for pain or
literally to make suffer in res in
reciprocity in return you know
antipathan so a strong desire kupitatum
we saw that before with the desire to
take Vengeance before so the strong is
not really part of what's going on here
but returning pain for pain
repondendi right to respond in kind with
Dolores dolor is pain suffering anguish
it's got a wide range of things so
somebody made us suffer we want to make
them suffer in return and he goes on and
he says the difference between his
definition and ours cannot be explained
briefly but then he does consider
something else another possible
objection well what about wild animals
don't wild animals become angry as well
and he says they do so without the
provocation of being wronged why does he
say that because wild animals don't have
a sense of right and wrong they just
respond to threats in the environment or
to you know being injured or something
like that you pull the cat's tail for
Seneca the cat is not saying you have
done me in Injustice and now I will get
angry and maybe swipe at you it's just
it's just a stimulus response and so he
says that wild animals
All Creatures except for the human being
are Without Anger uh be although anger
is reason's enemy it comes only into
being where reason resides there's
something unique about human beings wild
animals have impulses frenzy ferocity
aggression but they have no more have
anger than they have luxury even though
they're less self-controlled than humans
when it comes to certain Pleasures so
that's some that's an objection that
could apply to all of these definitions
and Seneca says uh no no you wild
animals aren't really angry at all he
goes on to consider two other things
that we should think about as we're
talking about
definitions he says what anger is what
era anger is has been sufficiently
explained and how it differs from
wrathfulness
uh is plain and he says here's an
analogy it's the same way that being
drunk differs from being a drunkard and
being afraid differs from being fearful
what's the difference here well some
people are much more disposed towards
anger a drunkard gets drunk all the time
right that's part of who they are and
being fearful means that you feel fear
much more often than the average person
much more easily so some people are you
know we could call them wrathful we
could also call them irritable would
work as well they are more prone to
being angry and he says someone who is
angry so angry at a particular time
might not be wrathful someone who is
wrathful might sometimes not be angry
but they are more disposed to be so
the other thing that he says that's
really quite interesting and here he's
referencing a rather sophisticated
understanding of the emotions that is
coming apart from the stoics but also
from other sources there were many
different kinds of anger that were
singled out and discussed categorized
right and he actually goes so far
towards the end
is saying that there are a thousand
varieties a thousand types kinds right
of this polymorphous this many shaped
evil and so he says that um these
categories that distinguish different
kinds of anger with a differentiated
terminology in Greek lack their own
labels in Latin so I'll pass them by and
then he says but we do have a vocabulary
in Latin and we cover a lot of things so
we have bitter amaros right we have
harsh akirbos
testy stomachus which is coming from
Greek right uh frenzied rabiosis the
word we get rabies from right uh ranting
clamosus clamor is shouting or you know
screaming or something like that
difficult difficulties cognate term
right there prickly asper which and he
says these are all different kinds of
anger and we could also include among
this peevish
when we say that somebody is more Rose
they're just kind of like you know
always having something bad to say
always looking on the
um
irritable side of things a
hypersensitive sort of wrathfulness he
says and he says there's certain forms
of anger that simmer down short of
shouting some that are frequent and
difficult to shake some that are
savagely physical and not very verbal
some that let loose in a torrent of
bitter abuse and curses some forms don't
go beyond complaining and sulking others
are deep and weighty and inward turning
and he doesn't give those names but
these are all different sorts of anger
but they all fit
under at least one of these definitions
maybe not Aristotle so much but the ones
that he is providing at the very
beginning so there's a lot of different
types of anger a lot of ways in which
anger you could say shapes and itself
and gets manifested in a person's
attitudes and actions and feelings and
words all these sorts of things that we
see even their facial expressions but
they all have the same basic structure
that these definitions allow us to wrap
our heads around